least 15 people have been killed by
Russian shelling in the southern
Ukrainian city of kherson some bodies
lay out in the open overnight as
Emergency Services struggle to respond
under the barrage of missiles the
governor says hospital patients have
been transferred to other areas for
their safety Russia has stepped up
attacks on the city which Ukraine retook
earlier this month
meanwhile Ukraine is racing to restore
electricity supplies as temperatures
reach Sub-Zero in many areas Russian
missiles have damaged nearly half of the
country's power facilities officials
have urged people to stock up on
Essentials President valade merzelensky
says his government is working hard to
keep households warm let's get an update
from Rory challenge joining us from Kiev
so two days after a barrage of Russian
missiles put millions of ukrainians out
of power and water Rory are things now
getting back to normal at all
well certainly last night's looking out
across the city behind me it was a very
different site to the previous uh two
basically uh the electric glow that
familiar glow had returned to many of
the windows uh compare that to the
nights before which were deathly quiets
and Inky black it was very eerie being
out on the streets you could just see
the faintest glimmer of Candlelight
coming from from some windows so the
situation is markedly improved that's
not to say it is totally back to normal
the president's uh Vladimir zielensky
said last night that power is now back
for half of the 12 million people who
had been left without power on Wednesday
when those missiles came in so six
million people are still shivering in
unheated Apartments without being able
to charge phones or or do cooking on
electric stoves Etc
now nobody believes that this is the
last wave of Russian missiles that are
going to be coming in there are
generators arriving from the United
States and Europe to try and help out
but I think many people here are
expecting this is going to be a long and
cold and for lots of people powerless
winter as Vladimir Putin tries to exert
the maximum
impacts and maximum leverage over
Ukraine and its backers using missiles
and the weather and today Rory is a
Sombra day marking the commemoration of
the 1932 Soviet made famine in Ukraine a
commemoration of special significance
this year
hmm
yeah it's called the halodemore in
Ukraine it happened in 1932 1933 and
since 1998 the four Saturday of November
has been uh marked as a lot of more
Memorial Day now the ukrainians have
long asserted that this man-made famine
was a genocide that it was basically the
Soviets trying to repress Ukrainian
national identity using starvation as a
tool and a growing number of countries
agree with that assessment calling it a
genocide most recently Romania Moldova
Ireland and soon to be followed by
Germany and I think in in the coming
days they've all recognized the hello
Deborah's genocide Germany is soon to do
that the Russian view is different the
Russians say and I have always said that
essentially that famine that starvation
uh didn't just affect Ukraine it
affected other parts of the Soviet Union
too but this year because of the war the
halotemore memorial has extra resonance
and ukrainians are again saying that
policies uh cooked up and exerted by
Moscow are killing ukrainians and again
ukrainians are saying that this what's
happening now amounts to a genocide in
the same way that the holonimo did many
many years ago all right Rory thank you
so much Rory challenge reporting from
Kiev